this play is you know harbors and
creates the biggest surf in the world
has known when it does come though this
place changes like it's the landscape
even looks different when the wind
changes I'll go windsurfing when the way
has changed I might go kite surfing you
know anything can happen whatever style
the ocean calls for I'm ready to bring
it on like changing an outfit you know
when the conditions change you change if
I could compare it to anything which is
hard to it would be like wearing a good
wet suit you know everything is like you
know fitted to your body perfectly and
it just feels great so I don't know what
do you think
[Music]
Oh keifa is basically my home surf break
this is the one way of that breaks more
often than anything
and it's one of the ways we're one of
the only ways where you can really do a
lot of the sports at a super high level
I mean I can wake up and go surfing here
immediately thereafter go wind surf and
go for a kite surf and then go stand a
paddling I mean there's a lot of options
at this place there's still this kind of
heaviness or even unknown back there to
you know part of this Coast and that
makes it exciting this town really you
know exudes that surfing style that's
surfing lifestyle everyone's here to you
know go in the water that's the first
and foremost confidence does go a long
way if you do have something that is so
nice like a suit you can carry that kind
of state of mind
[Music]
do you want to see me do more cool stuff
check out me ID surfing stand-up
paddleboarding in a suit on the GQ
Channel
you